[Música]
entre voces alarmistas y otras más
optimistas el 24 de febrero se cumplió
el peor de los pronósticos en europa
rusia decidió invadir ucrania bajo el
pretexto de desclasificar el país y
proteger a los ruso parlantes ha tomado
la decisión de lanzar una operación
militar sus abuelos y bisabuelos no
lucharon defendiendo nuestra patria para
que los neonazis de hoy se hicieran con
el poder de ucrania y lengua los rusos
entraron a la nación vecina por
distintos frentes por el norte noreste
desde el donbass y por el sur desde
crimea en manos rusas desde su ocupación
en 2014 junto al pánico entre los
ucranianos y las pérdidas de vidas
humanas las sanciones de occidente no
tardaron en llegar
a risoul conchi estamos decididos a
imponer costes masivos a rusia costes
que la aislarán aún más del sistema
financiero internacional y en nuestras
economías
las primeras conversaciones entre las
delegaciones rusas y ucranianas para
negociar el 28 de febrero no evitaron a
la avanzada rusa como una llamada de
auxilio del presidente ucraniano
demuestren que están con nosotros
demuestren que no nos dejarán demuestren
quiénes son verdaderamente europeos
entonces la vida vencerá a la muerte y
la luz a la oscuridad
con la caída de gerson el 3 de marzo la
primera derrota ucraniana el sufrimiento
solo acababa de empezar las mayores
víctimas hasta el momento los civiles
espero que mi esposa haya muerto rápido
ese momento muy guay espero que en este
momento mi esposa esté en el cielo el
que todo haya sido perfecto en su vida
en his life tras otros bombardeos contra
civiles como el del teatro de mariupol
uno de los puntos de inflexión de la
guerra se vivió a principios de abril
tras descubrir decenas de cadáveres en
lucha tirados en las calles a maniatados
algo por lo que la comunidad
internacional empezó a hablar de
genocidio
todos los la verdad del asunto usted no
lo que pasó en mucha putin es un
criminal de guerra
con ayudas multimillonarias
ucrania consiguió hacer retroceder a los
rusos dejar que la segunda ciudad del
país a mediados de mayo pero no lograron
salvar mariupol que cayó en manos rusas
el 21 de mayo
como decimos diferente
actualmente la avanzada rusa se
concentra en el este y en el horizonte
el fin de la guerra es muy incierto